in this video we're gonna talk about how
to visualize data in particular we're
gonna use something called a stem stem
and leaf a stem and leaf plot and what's
useful about this is it essentially
allows you to show all of your data and
show a lot of detail about all of the
numbers in your data set well at the
same time having a good sense about how
those numbers in your set are
distributed right here I have a set of
numbers when I just look at this it
really doesn't make a lot of sense to me
it's just a bunch of numbers to me I
have no sense or are more of them closer
to 20 or 30 or more of them closer to 80
or theirs is their median or their mode
30 or 40 or 84 I have no idea just
looking at this list of numbers but
using a stem and leaf plot hopefully
some of this will become a little bit
more apparent and the idea here is is to
list kind of the most significant digit
in each of those numbers in the stem so
when we talk about the most significant
digit these numbers right here they
range let's see we have a number that we
have a two here that looks like we have
a one that looks like our lowest number
and it goes all the way up to looks like
goes all the way up to 84 and has a
bunch of numbers in between and the
teens and the 20s and the 30s 40s 50 60
s so on and so forth so it looks like
the most significant digit here is the
tens digit so let's write it right here
let's write our tens digit tens digit
and the tens digit could be a zero one
two three four let me write this a
little bit bigger 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 or let
me scroll down a little bit or an 8 or
an 8 these digits will represent our
stem so I'm going to draw this little
line around here this is going to be our
stem right there
that right there is our stem in the stem
and leaf in the stem and leaf
plot for a number like 1 the 10th it is
zero you could imagine it as zero one
for a number like 84 the intensity is
obviously 8 so what I'm going to do is
rewrite all of these numbers here what
I'm going to use it using the
stem-and-leaf plot and the technique
here and I'm just gonna show you by
example let's go through each of these
numbers let's say I want to write 35 so
35 let me cross it out
35 so it has a tens digit of 3 I'll put
a 5 right here that tells me that 35 is
one of my numbers then I have 40 to
cross it out let me know I used it 42
I'm writing the ones digit as leaves
you're gonna see what I'm gonna do let's
see 38 well I have a 30 I'm going to
write an 8 here so I didn't have to
rewrite the 30 I'm just saying look I
have a 35 and I have a 38 I'm just
writing the ones digits within the three
stem within the tens place within the
30s place however you want to view the
30s bucket then we have a 57 57 we have
a 2 which is you could view as a 0 2 we
have a 2 we have 24 24 27 27 36 36 we
have a 35 a 38 and a 36 45 45 60 I think
you get the idea but just for the sake
of completion let's finish all of these
38 38 40 another 40 a 44 44 a 1 a 1 a
for another 44 a 48 so a lot of things
in this 40s bucket 48 and 84 84 a 38 38
a 20
so 2020 a 4 put that right there
0 4 a 2 getting a little monotonous but
let's just finish
4848 another 48 right there a 58 58 a 3
stick it up there that's 0 3 then we
have a 20 a 6 a 40 40 22 22 26 26 17 1 7
that's our first number in the teens
bucket at 18 18 a 44 0 a lot of things
in the 40s a fifty one fifty one sixty
two thirty one thirty one twenty seven
twenty seven forty eight forty eight 35
35 almost done 27:37 58 58 and
twenty-one and we have our twenty one
and just like that it was a little
monotonous but we essentially just
rewrote this list of numbers down here I
have every number represented we haven't
lost any information here I know every
number I could go start with this and I
could list tell you every number that I
had in my original list I have a six I
have a twenty seven I have a 38 a 35 so
we haven't lost any information but
what's neat about this representation is
when the numbers are written this way we
actually you know we actually save ink
because you don't have to rewrite the 40
to 45 you just write the ones digit but
more importantly we kind of understand
how the numbers are distributed that we
have a bunch of numbers in the 40s and
30s and 20s that's where most of the
numbers are we have very few numbers up
in the 80s and we have no numbers in the
70s we have very few we have a lot on
the ones but still most of them are
focused in this range over here so this
is just one of many many many ways to
visualize data that you
we'll run into in your mathematical or
statistical futures but I just wanted to
expose you to this